we just wanted to say thank you so much
for watching this show this year we have
had a lot of fun we robo called the FCC
we baked the world's largest marble cake
to spite the leader of Turkmenistan and
we climbed a fake Mount Everest to show
why climbing the real one is a bad idea
and we did an elaborate musical to tell
a coal tycoon to eat but we haven't
actually heard from Bob Murray yet but
I'm sure he loved it we also we also got
obsessed with a Japanese mascot called
cheetah you may remember that cheatin
was the hyper-violent unofficial otter
for the Japanese city of Sasaki and also
the star of videos like this one
excellent
that's excellent
now after su Saki broke ties with cheats
on their official mascot Shinjo kun was
left alone and look yeah yes exactly
that broke our heart so so we did
something uncharacteristically sweet for
us and we created our own replacement
mascot Qi John a nearsighted otter we
actually sent him to Japan to find
Shikoku I will admit and he came on a
little strong at first but eventually
they became great friends and have been
living in Sasaki together ever since the
whole saga was heartwarming wholesome
and basically the exact opposite of what
it feels like being alive right now I've
actually been thinking a lot about these
two lately because next year let's face
it is going to be unpleasant it is a
presidential election year so things are
going to get even more toxic than they
already are and lately I found myself
often craving for these twos a
particular brand of unmitigated joy so I
recently tried to get in touch with them
and why here's what happened
it had been a rough year and he John was
very sad he missed his friends who lived
very far away so he decided to write
them a letter he wound up and threw it
as far as he could
[Music]
on a distant Shore Chi John and
shinji-kun sat by the river the tide was
about to change
dear friends the letter said I wanted to
call you but I have a TMT so this seemed
like a more reliable option it's been an
exhausting year and next year is looking
worse I wish we could see each other he
John reading the letter broke their
utter hearts it was so sad he John had
AT&T
suddenly she John had an idea she John
and ginger couldn't packed everything
they'd need for a long journey and
borrowed a snack for two on the way to
the airport they said goodbye to all the
local fish we're dead replied the local
fish but good luck gee John and
shinji-kun was so excited for their
13-hour flight although the same could
not be said of everyone stuck between
two giant otters yet again at last
America
[Music]
right away they had trouble fitting in
they took what they assumed was the
subway and soon they were in the heart
of New York
America's Sasaki
[Music]
but no one there seemed to recognize he
Joe are you sure he has a television
show asked Shinjuku
they found a club for comedy maybe he
John was a member that man looks just
like him it must be his adult son
[Music]
emboldened by his two drinks tea John
tried comedy himself chi John killed
local fish really do be like that
someone heard they had been looking for
TVs best late-night host and told them
where to find him they had come to the
right place
but this wasn't he John the couldn't be
this man was fun charming and handsome
very handsome said ginger kun-hee John
couldn't be here because he John was sad
but how could anyone be sad at a place
like NBC XI John said he John needs us
but they started to worry that they
would never find him they sat down a
moment to rest and a local artist
captured their sadness
[Music]
gee John and Shinjo didn't
recognize themselves then again whoever
really does in the eyes of others gee
John and shinji-kun had reached the end
of the city there was nowhere left to
look their hope
dwindle dwith the daylight the tide
hadn't changed the way they'd wished but
that's the funny thing about tides they
might not change when you want them to
but they never stay the same
[Music]
[Applause]
hey John had been trying to Sisu sake in
the end it was Sasaki who saw him it was
a good surprise he John hadn't realized
surprises could be cool anymore
for the first time in a long time he
John dared to hope soon it will be a new
day he John said where we're from
[Applause]
you